oh hi yeah well today is May Day and I
distribute a paper as you can see trying
to daily what do you think about the
distributing of a Chinese government
newspaper I don't know I think it's
strange you can't huh because China
viven it is the worst of histamines
tomorrow that's for sure the worst
systems yes there's no such things in
China that people can do this isn't you
know not so there's a protest from this
point I think entities
it's very tolerant yeah everything they
have every day job let me read further
college graduates under 25 is 54 so
that's discussed oh you know I was the
same boat as you in 1991 I got out of
school and there were no jobs around and
what do I have to tell I like I was a
bricklayer I can smile work I did
whatever I could to find a job has the
progressive movement and the anti-war
movement been too slow to protest
President Obama and that kind of hurt me
cause it's I mean I think that there was
a there was a lot of IIIi certainly will
admit to being swept up in some of the
euphoria like it was the president look
different than any other president
before talked differently other
president before and then it ended up
acting very much like any centrist
Democratic president and so the
tremendous amount of disappointment with
regards to them what's the significance
of the zombie March um I represent most
people in America on this planet
everyone acts like a
we I feel like even the people in this
movement are zombies in terms of not
thinking for themselves
besides performance art what should
people be doing you know something
simple like sending bat sending you know
when you get those mailers from banks or
whatever sending that putting really
heavy cardboard and sending it back to
them they have to pay for the postage
for that what do you think people are
going to get that idea based on this no
cuz everyone wants to follow exactly the
Occupy movement like it's fun now let's
go follow yesterday yeah so okay so on
the south side of Bryant Park for the
made a general strike the occupied
guitar me is about to march down Fifth
Avenue to Madison Square Park and then
Union Square Park and we're gonna go
with them
those who believe that Obama's pretty
good like Randy Rock sorry Randy he
isn't about his foreign policy is
terrible is as bad as Bush's he's taking
away more of our individual rights and
civil liberties and Bush ever did what
do you make of the Obama
administration's crackdown on medical
marijuana dispensaries and taking
decriminalization off the table think
he's running for reelection that's what
I think but when he was running for
election he said the opposite well
that's what I mean right
agent Thomas it another stinking good to
see it it does not make him tough to arm
these people there's nothing tough about
it nothing
[Music]
what do you say would be the differences
between the vibe here you know on May
Day then during the original occupation
of Zuccotti Park last fall you know now
everybody got time to digest Occupy Wall
Street get it in this system understand
what we're about so this is the
culmination at that point you know where
we actually start you know you know put
what not words to power you know how do
you feel about the Obama
administration's foreign policy it sucks
we're extremely disappointed his foreign
policy essentially is a continuation of
the bush foreign policy it's a very
aggressive foreign policy it's based on
lies it's a foreign policy that it's
intended to serve the interest of the 1%
and as the rest of us 99% putting a lot
of veterans and active-duty gi's and
their families that are paying the price
worldwide rebel songs sing out loud oh
not long hang on man it won't be long
we're wide rebel songs hang on man
thank you very much